evening thank you for joining us on 8
news now at 11 i'm brian loftis and i'm
denise valdez the fbi of las vegas and
metro surrounded a northwest
neighborhood earlier today officials say
an agent was involved in a shooting at a
home near hualapai and anne road
victoria saha joining us live with a
look at what that situation looks like
right now victoria
brian and denise it started off as a
barricade situation but right now you
can see the lights are off in this house
behind me we just saw several unmarked
police vehicles leaving the property
the fbi of las vegas confirmed thursday
there was an agent involved shooting
near northwest valley home where there
was a barricade earlier in the day fbi
and metro officers had nearby streets
closed for hours and a chopper flying
over the neighborhood the focus a home
on roofian road right now very little is
known but the fbi did confirm someone
was hurt in that shooting and is
receiving medical attention the fbi
takes all shooting incidents involving
our agents or task force members
seriously
in accordance with fbi policy the
shooting incident is under investigation
by the fbi's inspection division
eight news now did learn of the identity
of the person who owns this house but
are choosing to not share that
information until officials give us a
confirmation stay with us as we learn
any new details reporting live tonight
victoria saha live local now